do pretty good man pretty good pretty
good we're blessed how's your day today
excellent man I Joly you ain't going to
lie I didn't hear a lot of it it's okay
just talking about what the Engel is and
how some Muslims said it's the Bible
some Muslims said it's not the Bible so
this some musl said that we don't know
what it is so you know it's it's
interesting yeah there's a CH do you
have time for the question the different
question different
question different qu the question right
now is what is
theel I mean I don't think we can go
anywhere for that politic but why not we
can go we can I'm telling you when we at
when we deal with this question it's
gonna lead you right to Christ in the
Bible we'll see we'll see okay and I can
give you my what I think was a what I
think most people understand is Islam is
what Jesus was preaching mostly that's
what we understanding yeah and the
question is what is that you sound you
sound a little muffled by the way though
they're saying they're saying that your
sound sounds muffled uh I was just
saying the inil we believe is what Jesus
was preaching when he was in the when he
was in his time basically is it is it
any better guys I mean I can I can hear
him just fine but oh they can't hear me
there it's you sound your mic is muffled
that's what it sounds
like like like you got something
covering the mic or
something you have on headphones or
anything no I don't have a headphone
on
maybe yeah you're you're you're good
enough just just just make sure you uh
you just sound yeah they're saying it
sounds fine now so yeah just make sure
you uh you know speak directly and it
and it's not muffled or anything so yeah
he said he said guys for those who
didn't hear him he said that you know
from the Muslim understanding the inil
is what Jesus was preaching and so
that's the question is what is that what
was he
preaching oh I mean I mean okay so we
can have this B we can have a
conversation but remember I don't know
if you remember the last conversation we
had kind of turn left so I want to start
with something before we we can go to on
this road but I want to start with
something else which is I want you to
say three things three good things about
Prophet Muhammad it's a challenge just
good not cising nothing give me three
good
things I didn't know you were the host
but okay host no I I'll follow you I
want people to see that no no no it's
okay I'm a I'm a guest I'm a guest on
your um I'm a guest on your live so I
I'll I'll make sure I indulge and engage
I don't want I don't want the people to
vote me off so I appreciate it all right
for sure all right host uh three good
things about Muhammad yes uh if I'm G be
real with you man
I I don't got
any none
none okay can I say three things that he
did good sure
okay all right for example you believe
uh um you know how they were treating
females in AR world before Prophet
Muhammad when they have female daughter
some of them would bury them alive okay
did that St after
him did it did it thought
that I don't know did it I don't know
did it I believe it did we don't see
that
anymore well from what I saw if it's
stopped I saw Muhammad say that the one
who buries the woman who buries her
daughter her infant daughter and the one
who is buried will go to
hell sorry what was it Muhammad said he
didn't stop no I I didn't say that he
didn't stop it I'm saying when it comes
to that topic he said that the woman who
buried her infant daughter and and the
one who is buried the infant daughter
who's buried both go to
hell say who who said that
Muhammad and this says a an authentic
you want to see
it go for it yeah honestly it shocked me
when I saw
it all right let me see if I could pull
it up because I don't have it in my
archiv I just got to pull this up real
quick and do my God logic
thing let's see
him I'm disappointed on you though I
ain't gonna lie to you why you said you
couldn't find
anything was he wasn't a good man
bro he was not a good man even bad
people they do certain sometimes they do
good things even if believe he was a bad
person you can see a good effect while
people follow him but you could even
yeah the yeah the effects of people
follow them is terrible they they have
sex with children they take people's
wives they you know um adultery
temporary
marriage mutah and stuff like that
that's that's horrible the fruits of
Islam the fruits of Muhammad what it's
horrible bro it's it's
bad
thank you
nas all
right all right Sun Abu da
4717 let me actually put it on the
screen and get there so that everybody
can see it so no one thinks that logic
is lying you guys know logic never lies
no logic do you actually argue with like
uh smarter people yeah I do it all the
time oh do you got a YouTube channel or
something like
M okay I'm G check it out
thanks no because this is not showing
the the whole
side this is not this is not good for
you it doesn't it doesn't show you a
good picture it shows me an excellent
picture when I'm getting uh back
channels and messages from Muslims who
are converting and Muslims who are
saying why wow I never uh saw this
before and wow they've been teaching me
something different but you've helped me
research the the truth of Islam it's a
it's a real good look uh I'm doing
exactly what I'm supposed to be doing
man bringing people to the
light you know
okay so so this is uh this is Sun Abu is
great sah Sun Abu da
4717 all right okay says am report
reported the messenger of Allah as
saying the woman who buries alive her
newborn
girl and the girl who is buried alive
both will go to
hell this tradition has also been
transmitted by iban massud o from the
prophet to the same effect through a
different chain of narrators so even
yeah it's authentic even I massud was
narrating this
so the woman who buries her newborn girl
alive and the newborn girl alive who's
buried the baby the infant who hasn't
done nothing wrong will go to hell
that's what Muhammad is teaching that's
that's wrong first of all good no no I
mean even in the Muslim teaching because
anybody who's not
mature like does it have the maturity
level to understand the know like the
about God is automatically going to
heaven and there's a lot of Hadith that
support that there's no Hadith that
support that bro okay bro look see see
when you say that there's no topic have
you studied all of it I've studied this
subject pretty well
man look I'm giving you something right
now this is you said this is wrong like
so so is muhamed wrong for teaching this
how about this how about this logic you
see this this the the one just provide
me yeah okay because I I'm I'm not going
to lie to you I don't know about I never
seen it I don't know about it so I can
bring somebody who knows more about it
next time and you can have a discussion
with them because now you this to a lot
of people so yeah most of us don't know
about this so like it's a bad thing so I
want people to explain
this what what do you think that there
is what what do you think is could be a
possible
explanation for Allah sending to Hell
the newborn innocent child who's who was
buried alive by her mother how was how
is that what can they exp how can they
explain that away I'm I'm I'm saying I
don't know why he say say that's my
that's my problem it's not even the top
I'm talking about why he saying sah oh
why is it great sah yeah because it's
authentic I I want
that's the right it even says do you
like do you know who IB massud is not
really oh man yeah so IB massud he's one
of the four people that Muhammad said
you have to learn the Quran from he's
one of the four so he he's like legit
I'm I'm happy you bring it up never seen
I'm not going to lie to you so that's
good you brought it up but I want to I
want you to have this conversation with
somebody who actually knows the subject
not me no worries take take a screenshot
of this for me I want you to have this
take a screenshot I'm not gonna lie you
did okay good good all right so next
time we talk you know you can come back
um and tell me what you know someone who
whoever you trusted tell me what they
said to you and no instead of being a
person in the between let's just bring
somebody like I can bring somebody who
knows and you can talk to them okay yeah
I'm down for that bring bring someone
who who you trust knows and I'll
definitely have this conversation with
them no no worries yeah okay there's
there's another one I want to show you
it's of the same thing showing you I
don't know what website you're using you
got a collection down there okay go
ahead well well this is this is uh this
is sun.com so they just have uh they
have a bunch of Hadith I'm just in the
I'm just in the Sunan I'm in the sun Abu
daud collection okay you know so like U
let me just show you this is sun.com it
has like all these collections of Hadith
you got s bukari s Muslim anai stuff
like that sun Abu da so when I just
click Sun Abu da all the books that are
in Sun that that are available that they
have are here you know so I just um I
just went to it so when you click on one
of the books like for example I'm
clicking on this one
33 when I click on it it gives me all
the hadiths that are in that book in
AB you know so it's a good it's a good
website sun.com is used by
everyone I'll I'll take that one too for
sure so here's another one um because I
you know to to have this idea that you
know babies just go to heaven
automatically you know they never did no
sin no wrong they're innocent they
haven't reached the age of
accountability right they haven't had
puberty like you would think I mean it's
common sense like yeah they're innocent
they can they're going to go straight to
heaven and stuff no the Quran doesn't
teach or Islam doesn't teach that like
we just saw that Hadith that I showed
you now here's another one in um sahim
Muslim in sahim Muslim
um slipping my mind what's that Hadith
in sahim Muslim guys where it says uh I
I got it I'll just do this per
Adventure put some key wordss
here all right here it is too late
n
so it says in s now watch I want you to
screenshot this too take a
screenshot let me know when you got
it I got it we read it
though so it says
Aisha the mother of the Believers said
that Allah's messenger was called to
lead the funeral prayer of a child of
the ansar are okay I said so this is
Aisha talking
now so Aisha said Allah's messenger
there is happiness for this child who is
a bird from the birds of paradise for it
committed no sin nor has he reached the
age when one can commit sin right so so
this child who passed away Aisha is
saying she's happy for the child because
the child didn't commit sin nor was the
child at the age where he can commit sin
so he didn't even reach puberty yet
right so he's inoc sin he's going
straight to paradise Aisha
says so Muhammad responds he said Aisha
per Adventure that means stop hold
on Muhammad says hold on it may be
otherwise so Aisha thinks the bab's
going to heaven M Muhammad says hold on
it may be otherwise so that baby may be
going to hell why because God created
for Paradise those who are fit for it
while they are yet while they were yet
in their father's
loins and created for hell those who are
to go to hell he create now watch this
here's the important part he created
them for hell while they were yet in
their father's
lowings okay
so before they can even do anything
before they're even born Allah creates
certain people for paradise and creates
certain people for hell now this isn't
talking about that Allah pause pause I'm
sorry but if God knows everything if God
knows we're going to go Hell or Heaven
before he created us does that
automatically say that that's not
nothing new he order we do we not KN
like he knows everything he created us
does he know like we're going to go Hell
or Heaven there's a yeah there's a
difference there's a difference between
God's or Allah's forn knowledge like
what he already knows beforehand and
then what he determines what he actively
you know makes happen this isn't talking
about oh Allah just knows who's going to
go to hell before it it's not what it
says it says that he created them for
hell he created them for hell what I'm
saying is if he knew they're G to go to
hell well that he created them it means
does that mean he created them for hell
no just him knowing that they're going
to go to hell doesn't mean that he
created them for hell no it's not him
again if I know that you're about to
touch the fire it doesn't mean that I
made you touch the fire or you know
lured you know made a purpose for you to
touch the fire no my for knowledge is
not the same as me determining what
happens with you determining your
actions or determining your um your
destination there's a difference
Allah knows if you're saying he's all
knowing yes he's all knowing and knows
the people's destination yeah but it's
more than that not only does he know
people's destination he created them for
that specific
destination
understand what I'm
saying I mean you're wording it
differently but if he deep down think
about the first one is the same one as
the second one be honest yeah yeah both
Hadith are well both I'm talking about
the statement you saying knowing where
you're going and knowing creating you
well knowing where you're going is the
same thing no it's
not no it isn't
but let me see if I can come up with an
example for you okay explain clarify
that I'm trying to come up with an
example for you
um if if if you know what I'm about to
do does that mean that you determined
what I was about to do if you already
know what I'm about to
do are you saying he's determining for
the people where they going to be yes
I'm saying
is I know what you're saying all you're
saying is he just knows it's not that he
determines it he just knows he give them
free will on their Earth no they don't
have free will there is no free will he
created them for
hell he created them for hell yes that's
what it says he created them for
hell while they were yet in their
father's loens
hey from
that I don't know what I don't know what
you're trying to say
though I'm saying that even in your
religion it doesn't matter if it's a
baby who's completely innocent or
whatever or someone who is grown up and
stuff like that it doesn't matter even
babies go to hell according to Islam and
it's Allah who created them for
hell it's not it's not that their
actions in this life you know causes
them to either go to heaven or hell no
Allah has already created them for
heaven or
hell doesn't matter what they do
even babies this is a baby that we're
talking this is a child that we're
talking about that might go to hell
according to Muhammad yeah I mean I'm
not going to give a commment on that
statement because I don't know the
background stories Hadi so usually had
has like a lot of stories behind it when
that happened so we we can discuss that
on a on the who's more knowled about
that of course and my understanding is
God can you know God created all of us
the people who goes heaven or hell he
created us and he if if we say he's all
know knowing means he knows when he
created us who's going to Hell or Heaven
but when we came to earth like you have
free will I have free will I might go to
Hell or Heaven but I have a free world
to come to talk to you here and not to
talk to you you know what I mean so yes
which means that Islam is false because
it teaches that you don't have free will
bro I understand the reality of that we
live in in reality we have free will we
choose our actions we choose what we do
and things of you chose to come up here
on my stage I chose to let you up we
have free will in reality but according
to Islam you don't so Islam does not
align with reality that's why this is
one of the reasons why I reject
Islam align with reality that that's the
craziest thing you heard man that's the
craziest thing you've heard and you've
been watching me for a while now yes
because come
on no because everything makes sense
Islam that so what I just showed you
that makes sense what I just showed
you the one you told me I need to learn
about more the Islam I know it makes a
lot of sense I I understand the Islam
that you said you said something very
keen the Islam that you know makes
perfect sense to you and here's my what
I'm this is what I'm saying this is what
I'm suggesting to you that the Islam
that you know is not the true Islam the
Islam that you've been taught that
you've learned growing up and been
taught at the mosque and by your parents
or by your teachers is not the Islam
that is in the Quran and the Hadith it's
a completely difference complet theth
there's there's a lot of Hadith not like
people can make like understand but the
Quran though like I read it before I
understand the mean that's the one I
know maybe I haven't read all of it I
haven't
know I'll tell you what um CA because
I'm wrapping up now but next time you
come next time you come listen next time
you come we will uh we'll go over we'll
go over the Quran and I'll show you I'll
show you the same stuff in the Quran
that that you will I mean if you're
honest and you know and you know you'll
you'll have to reject it I'll show you
it hold up I remember I don't know if
you remember the question I asked last
time I was trying to get this
answer what's the definition of
slave uh one who serves another who
serve another yeah or okay so does that
does that mean Jesus was a slave to the
father yeah so Jesus were
Muslim Muslims are slaves of the father
huh Muslims are slaves of the
father oh
yeah come on I know you that's why
you're hesitated no the you me the
father I mean not biological father and
sense of creation to to the father yeah
so I ask you again yeah are Muslims
slave of the
father we are a servant to
Allah refer Allah to the father it's
just a so is Allah is Allah the
Father the father yeah okay like when
you say the father like the Greeks like
when when Jesus when Jesus says when
Jesus says that God is his father who he
submits to and serves and is a slave
of is is all law the father of
Jesus okay can I can you define this
when you say a father biological or in
in the sense of
creation which one hold on hold on
sorry so when you say the father
yeah bro like I don't I don't understand
what's the difficulty true definition
when you say the the father what's the
what's the difficulty is Allah let me
ask you is Allah a father in any
sense like okay in the sense of like
people used to refer him as a father
like and the Jewish basically yeah and
Allah says that he's not the Jews the
father of the Jews Chapter 5 Verse 18
hold let me answer that you know when
the the Greeks Gods when they believe
what they that has nothing to do with
the Greeks my friend no come on stay
focused on the main point
bro okay so what are you trying to say
when you say the father in the sense of
is Allah a father in any sense no I'm
asking you which way it doesn't matter
in which way in any way is Allah a
father in any way okay I'll I'll explain
yes if is you if you're referring him as
a like as a quer okay show me show me
that in the Quran show me that in the
Quran linguistically I Allah yeah show
me in the Quran where Allah is a Father
Allah is not the creator of everything
yeah where does it say Allah is the
creator of everything that's what you
believe where does it say that he's the
father no no I'm think in the the Quran
it says that he's the father of
everything yeah show me that show me
where it says he's the father of
everything he is the creator of
everything show me where it says he's
the
father come on we are we playing this J
I'mma Be Back why are we playing this
slow I'm going be back
go come on let's be realistic and let's
have a conversation let not just did you
just say let's be realistic yes did you
just say that to me yes logic come
on okay when I say the father if you
refer him as the creator of everything
well you know when we say the father of
uh modern science he didn't like
biologically created it we just say the
father of that because he is the one who
created it and that says God is the
father does that make
sense than your
de sorry some dog was trying to get buck
with me
all right do you hear why I was saying
though so uh so so so you're saying yes
Allah is a father in some sense right
why the that he's creat why you trying
to put words on my mouth are you
understanding what I'm saying that's
what you said you literally said that
Allah is a father in the sense that he
is the creator of all things listen
again oh they put the Paul yes find
out now we're not going to put the poll
up bis I like B B boy he's
okay listen I was trying to say okay you
know when we say the that's what you
said Biz boy you know I'm not putting
words in your mouth you literally said
that okay okay let me explain and exp
like say that say whatever you
understand okay say it back to me what
whatever you
understand I understood
that from your you're saying that Allah
is not a father in a biological sense
that he had sex and gave birth but that
he is a father in the sense that he is
the creator of all things that's what
you
said okay for example when we refer
people
as like the father of your your M your
mic is low your mic is very low when we
refer people oh the father of the modern
history or whatever we referring them
because they are they are the first one
to discover or they are the creator of
that subject yes and that says yes he is
the father of everything because he
created
everything yeah I think you're cutting
off
I didn't say disc bro
created sorry I was uh putting my
putting my address in can you hear me
yeah I can hear you now I yeah I heard
everything you said though so um in the
sense that he's the source or the
beginner of of everything is that what
you're
saying yeah he created everything that's
what I'm trying yeah so he's the he's
the source of everything so that's why
he's in that sense he's the father of
everything so show me where the Quran
says that do show me where it says that
the that Allah is the father and I'm
tell I'm saying is in the Quran I can
find I can find a ver that say
he that doesn't mean that he's seen as
the father though you're you're you're
innovating or making up something that
doesn't exist in the in your
religion
if that's what you think no that's what
it is like that's why you can't you
can't P you can't give me a verse to
back up your Doctrine like I'm I hear
your theology right now show me a verse
that backs up your theology you're
stealing from the you're stealing from
the
Bible the the Quran emphatically rejects
this idea that Allah is a father in any
way in any way
because because the people who come off
before it
they took it to a different like the
L with the language they took it in a
different sense and people start praying
to the prophet and it's no no the Jews
the Jews said that they were the Jews
and the Christians said that they were
sons of God in the sense that they were
his beloved that he loved them and Allah
says
no
no you're not that's chapter 5: 18
says the Jews and the Christians say we
are the sons of of Allah his beloved
that's in the sense that they were
saying he was a son not that they was
they were biological children but that
he loved them
dearly and all and Allah says no he
rejects
that okay when he rejected it because
because they were not the same and the
right path or he rejected it because of
that he rejected it because he's not a
father at
all he rejected it because he's not a
father at all he literally says you
can't he literally says you cannot come
to him as a son you can only come to him
as a
slave hum was all humans are born to be
enslaved though are they not are we we
not supposed to follow are we meant to
follow or
Sor no we're not just supposed to be his
his slaves we are God loves us as and
sees us as his CH the true God loves us
and sees us as his children as we are he
is our parent that's how he sees us but
Islam degrades that to know it's just a
master versus and and a servant that's
all it is well the true God tells you
you're more than that Jesus tells you
you are his
son you are the a son of the Father in
Heaven who looks after
you better than he looks after the birds
in the sky better than he looks after
the dandelion he clothes the flowers how
much more will he clothe you uh he takes
care of the the sparrow the birds how
much more will he will your father this
is what Jesus says how much more will
your Father in heaven look after you and
feed you and provide with you what you
need that's how Jesus describes God to
us and Muhammad comes and degrades that
relationship demeans that
relationship it's it's almost like when
um when people who support abortion they
have to they have to
dehumanize demean the baby in order to
make an argument like they say oh it's
just a fetus or oh it's just the clump
of sales they they bring the value down
to have an argument
against against the baby and to be able
to un alive them that's what Satan want
Satan wants to bring the value of
humanity down he's been doing it from
the beginning he brings the value of of
of of man down black people they were no
more they were not they were not uh
humans they were only partial humans
bringing the value into meaning them
down so that they can attack them and
kill them same with the Jews that they
were they were not um not really humans
they were you know demons and stuff like
that demeaning them so to to have an
excuse to attack them in Islam it
demeans it demeans not just Jesus but
demeans all of mankind that says you're
just Allah's slaves you're not his
children it's demeaning you it's
bringing your value Down When God says
we are made in His
Image so you
know you there yeah yeah I'm I'm I'm
just listening to
you listening to me
preach but I don't know it's I don't I'm
not gonna lie to you like
I can like the knowledge I have
is is not to argue like not good to
argue we're just talking man I'm not I'm
not yeah I don't I don't expect you to
like I don't like from my learning why I
know
like why I believe like it doesn't
matter what like for me like I believe
is God so far didn't like me down as a
human I think following what Islam
taught me me like I'm
proud what have you ever read have you
ever read the gospels before
bro uh not the whole part but I was
talking to other people and so I read I
read like some part of it but not the
whole
you know what I'm you know what I'm GNA
start doing I'm GNA have a day when I go
live and I'mma just have these days
where I just read through the gospel I'm
just have some of those days do you have
a Bible on you at at home or do you have
access to a Bible I mean I I got
internet got
internet I I want you man on on on your
own time and whenever you can find time
you
know whatever you know I it's just for
your own education for your own
education bro for your own self-
knowledge I want you to
read the book of
Matthew I want you to read the book of
Matthew bro in it you have the gospel
you have where Jesus you have his birth
you have where he comes from and you
have his sermons his
teachings and what he says about God and
what he says about the people of God and
what God wants from man and that
connection that God has with man and why
he's here I want you if you on your own
time man to methodic like you know um
over a period of time just read go
through the Book of Matthew it's not
long it's only it's only 28
chapters no I'm not gonna lie even
before you say I was always funny to
read it is I like different perspective
hearing about different religion
I think to actually get to know your
religion you have to know
other I believe that so I don't mind I
don't mind looking it I'm I'm glad I'll
gladly do it when I have time not gonna
lie one more question this is okay sure
it might be not on the topic just I got
you on the phone so I will
ask
oh what ch
this is always whenever I talk to
Christian this is the question I always
never answer to me what
change like did God change his mind
after Christ like before Christ in after
Christ the perspective of religion and
Christianity the perspective of God is
totally different what was what made
that change why God Chang his mind or
was that always the plan
so if that was always the plan the test
for the people before Christ and after
Christ is not the so is that that means
is he not merciful I'm trying to ask
this question but you get what I mean
yeah
okay so in Jesus time and before his
time the doctrine and theology was the
same it was the exact same it's it's
hold on
it's not until you get to the
Quran where you see a complete and utter
change and
difference and this is how we know like
look like this is this is so important
to me bro what's so important to me is
consistency is
continuity you know what's what's why I
Love The Gospel is because it lines up
with the Old Testament why I love the
Old Testament is because it highlights
the gospel It Works hand in hand it
there's continuity you see it all you
see the flow when you get to the Quran
you there you see the the cut off where
it's absolutely disconnected from the
previous scriptures and its
Theology and I'll show you that I'll
show you like little examples of
that perspective is the opposite is like
from my perspective is like I got so
much similarity with
the and I
different and all that and not doing
like you just have to believe
mostly but but bis boy what's up how how
can you say that when you've never read
the gospel or the Old Testament I'm
saying like I'm not going to lie like I
have a conversation with people that's
that's how get more of my information so
yeah that that means nothing bro that
don't mean nothing if you you got to I'm
going to show you like when I when I get
time because I you know I'm on I'm not
on the road right now but you know when
I get time my the next time I see you I
I want I'm G show you I'mma show you the
consistent theme of God and his son in
the Old Testament and the new I'm going
show you the Old Testament where it
talks about God and his son being the
Messiah to save the world and redeem the
world of their sins I'm going to show
you the New Testament that confirms that
and fulfills what what was said already
I'm going to show you that that same
line of thinking that same thread that
same consistency and then I'm G show you
where the Quran completely rejects it
I'm G show you it I'm G show you I'll
look I'll look forward to see
it I like discussing about this every
time I this discussion but let's be
peaceful like
this like yeah of course I'm not going
to lie this is
more the previous people I seen because
doesn't look good let's try on it I know
I know you're doing your own work but I
know you can do better that's why I'm is
it on me or is it on them I I treat
everybody the same I mean but come on
now you you have to be a bigger person
in their religion so they be going to be
defensive you know that yeah instead of
calling them names and cussing them out
I just kick them okay that's that's
[Laughter]
good I I think if that's if that's the
law I think you doing better
than that's right I'll let you I'll let
you have a good time I don't know where
you seem to like you're going yeah out
in the about now but yeah be blessed man
and be
safe I'll be my
brother come to Christ
man take care
man